Did you know there's an entire chapter devoted to you in the darkhold.
No one taught me magic
Your power exceeds that of the sorceror supreme
It's your destiny to destroy the world.
Welcome back everyone. This is going to be
my Wandavision episode 9 finale video. There
were so many big reveals and so many big teasers
for Doctor strange 2 Captain Marvel two Spider-Man
3 is all explained what was going on with
that. Of course there were all kinds of post
credit scenes or if you're brand-new to the
channel. Be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos. I'll be doing episodes for falcon
winter soldier next is gonna start in a couple
weeks and there is a special bonus episode
for Wandavision will air next week all explained
what that is because there's a lot of confusion
about what's going on with that careful for
spoilers. If you have not seen the episode
yet will to start at the beginning of the
episode and work our way through the first
big thing. The title was actually called the
series finale, because it's literally the
series finale. But they're doing the sitcom
troops with the were trying to keep all the
titles of the episodes within the theme of
all the sitcoms, but the episode starts in
the street there with their big standoff gunslinger
moment where it left off and episode eight.
Wanda starts blasting Agatha with her magic
in then Agatha says that she's counting on
her using powers confirming the theory that
she was just trying to get wanted to use her
powers that she could absorb more of her chaos
magic when she says she takes magic from the
undeserving quote of quote. It's kind of my
think that's a reference the flashback we
saw where she drained her coven in her own
mother Evan or Harkness they battle about
a little more then we get a big Wizard of
Oz reference when she throws the car at Agatha
Harkness, crushing her in the house in a very
Wizard of Oz style like she's the wicked witch
of the West. Obviously is the beginning the
episodes is no way that was going to kill
her. She reappears later almost instantaneously
floating in the air, but for just a hot second
things chill out and vision flies up, but
it's white vision in scarlet which is isn't
quite sure what to make of it and I love the
way they play that slow reveal because we
the audience no more than she knows we know
exactly what was going to happen here, like
his hands are on both sides her face. Oh he's
deafly gonna trying crusher school in now
we get a good look at him in the light of
day. You can also see some of the subtle changes
they made his design. So he's not an exact
copy of vision just painted white like there's
some structural differences in his school
in his voice obvious it sounds very different,
but the white vision in the comics was very
unfeeling and robotic he had no motions because
it never wonder man's mental patterns to give
him a personality so they try to make this
version of vision feel very robotic. That's
why his voice sounded the way it did Agatha
Harkness comes back and sort of acts is the
comedic relief, but also the villain of the
episode as well. She shows up and says oh
what you can into your ex and your new boyfriend
showed up at the same party is sort of like
the episode of Doctor Who where rose realize
there were two versions of the Doctor we then
check back in with Monica Rambeau was being
held captive in active this house, but we
get the full reveal of what's going on with
Evan peters they revealed that he is the Ralph
that she kept speaking of all season. My husband.
Ralph but no big multi-verse explain her no
big twist. He just a regular person living
in West you New Jersey, and just a really
coincidence that he happens to look like Quicksilver
from the Fox X-Men films that it was a multi-verse
stuff during the episode all explained that
when we get to alternate dimensions. We start
talking at that post credit scene in the future
of Billy and Tommy Wiccan and speed those
also all the stuff that Agatha Harkness was
trying to warn scarlet which about all somethings
come and you have no idea what you unleash
are gonna need my help all explained that
to. Don't worry that gets into bigger multi-verse
stuff, but I do love the way that Monica Rambeau
sort of solve the situation. She does wind
up using her powers. She doesn't totally understand
how they work, but throughout the episode.
She does have a couple moments where she sort
of starts to realize how they work, so she
sees Agatha's energy from the beads ripped
those off in obvious he finds out that Evan
peters, Ralph character is just a total lightweight
so takes them down pretty easily. I did love
that they gave them a name like Ralph Boehner
like you can laugh even though the joke is
kind of stupid like okay this is definitely
a stupid name to give someone, but it is kind
of funny because it's so stupid. Even Ralph
lasted his own last name your Boner ha ha
you look around what he calls his man cave.
It is very reminiscent of Quicksilver's man
cave from X-Men days of Future past with any
of your big vision versus white vision fight
scene in they do use their powers and more
of all the ways that we've seen them do in
previous Marvel movies like Avengers age of
old on in then obviously Captain America Civil
War Avengers infinity war as silly as it may
have seemed when they first started having
that debate like vision tries to give them
a logic problem stop him dead in his tracks
and knobs he totally works, I did like the
creative way that they try to write this one
of vision's defining traits is these very
verbose very well read and he's very philosophical.
So is a very creative way to have to God tier
powerful characters just go at each other
and try to solve the problem of what am I
if I'm not vision but then hits vision throws
the ship of Theseus problem at him. If you
not familiar with that they did a pretty good
job of explaining it. During this scene here
where they sort of talk it out. The whole
idea being that if you repaired the ship of
Theseus one plank at a time by the time you
replaced all the planks would the ship still
be the original ship of Theseus or would be
something completely different is that the
same object. If you replaced all the parts
of that object in this hex version of vision
is basically that he is completely replaced
from the ground up so is he truly vision then
white vision is like well I don't have the
mind stone. So technically I'm not vision
either, but were both vision because they
both think that there vision in that is the
conundrum that sort of stops them dead in
his tracks. But then obviously white vision
just flies off and you know see him again,
but all reference white vision again in a
second. When I talk about the end of the episode
in the way that hex vision goes out because
they have that conversation like oh yeah were
deafly gonna bring you back at some point.
But then a scarlet which makes her way into
the middle of town you start to see Agatha
turn the people against her by releasing them
from her control. They all start begging for
mercy and some of them revealed that they
been under the hex spell for so long that
they don't even remember all the details of
their original life. To begin with is all
part of Agatha's plan to get scarlet which
to want to get rid of her powers like she
wants her to feel as bad as possible look
what you've done to these people you're torturing
them. What you give me your powers and I'll
fix everything which of course is allies.
We find out. But then the answer the big question
of what's going on with her book of dark magic.
It really is the Darkhold it just a redesigned
completely different MCU version of the Darkhold
than the one we saw during agents of shield.
If you did watch that series that a whole
plot with the Darkhold on it was part of their
ghostwriter storyline because of all the stuff
that they set up and tease during this Wandavision
finale. I think the trying to be much more
comic book accurate with this version of the
Darkhold to the Darkhold of the book of the
damned is Agatha Harkness calls it was created
by the elder God Chthon who is the god of
chaos. So when Agatha says that Wanda is using
chaos magic that makes her the scarlet which
in this a whole chapter devoted to her in
the Darkhold that means that I believe that
they're trying to set up cut stone inside
the MCU. There were all these larger theories,
everyone had about who Agatha Harkness was
tied to what was a larger force behind her
where she was getting her power from just
based on the facts as they are presented during
Wandavision in the way they talk about these
references they're talking about Chthon the
whole thing in the comics is that he basically
creates the book and uses it as a conduit
to try and resurrect himself on earth. So
the whole ideas that he's trying to come back
to earth come into this main MCU dimension.
Obviously, we don't see that happened during
this Wandavision episodes, which it sounds
like they're teasing that is part of the plot
of Doctor strange 2 know is always possible
that because the MCU is very PG-13 for the
most part, and it's really hard to explain
Chthon to younger children that they might
change his character just a little bit for
Doctor strange 2 but like I said chaos magic
wand a scarlet witch inside the Darkhold it's
written about her Chthon is the god of chaos
and he wrote the Darkhold in the comics. He
also turns up in the wonder core mountains
which kind of seem like that's where Wanda
is at the end the episode in that post credit
scene, like utilities mountains around turn
it seems like is very Romani looking cabin
just seems like is meant to be a reference
to her comic book origin and their Backstory
in the wonder core mountains. But then Agatha
basically says that she supposed to be a being
whose more powerful than the source or supreme
stronger than Doctor strange, at least in
magic when she says she has no need for incantations
that should be pretty self-explanatory. It
means she doesn't need to speak the words
of spells when she weaves her magic. She just
does it innately and here's another big Doctor
strange 2 teaser. I feel like something that's
leading in the plot of Doctor strange 2. She
says that it's her destiny to destroy the
world. I feel like there's some sort of prophecy.
This written about her. This is that she'll
help bring about the resurrection of Chthon
like the god of chaos through her chaos magic.
It is not meant to be a direct house of M
reference that was mostly what was going on
with the hex that was their whole house of
M reference but then is Agatha tricks scarlet
witch into bringing down the hex like see
how you're torturing these people she's okay
final fix everything, so she starts taking
the hex down, but inadvertently also starts
to kill vision like he starts to disappear
than Billy and Tommy start to disappear as
she brings the hex backup to save them. They'll
go back to normal, but they're all facing
the sword agents in the make a really big
Avengers assemble reference when the family
circles up together that the big standoff
moment make a bunch of Wiccan and speed comic
book references when vision says we didn't
really train you for this in the scarlet which
says, but you were born for it and then they
basically go around taking out the sword agents
using their powers. I did think it was probably
one of the more moments of the episode that
Tyler Heyward just unloads an entire clip
of his gun on Billy and Tommy Monica Rambeau
is able to save them from most of the bullets
and what's happening here is that her body
is basically made up entirely of light. So
she's able to neutralize most of the bullets
than Billy or Wiccan. However you want to
think about him use his powers of Telekinesis
to stop the last bullet his powers are basically
the exact same powers a scarlet which is obvious
he is not quite as powerful as her just because
he's really little, though I feel like a lot
of the Tyler Heyward stuff in the episode
was incredibly predictable I didn't think
he was quite as good of a villains Agatha
Harkness Catherine Hanh is Agatha Harkness
was fantastic during the series. The Tyler
Heyward character not so much then they start
to explain more of what happens to scarlet
which when Agatha leaches her powers as she
throws up the shield to stop Agatha's magic,
but Agatha uses that as an opportunity to
leach more for power and you start to see
scarlet which is hands turn black like is
the same thing that happened to her coven
in the flashbacks. The more Agatha can convince
her to use her powers the more she can take
from her leach from her. The faster scarlet
which starts to fade away you notice, though,
when Tommy is running around taking out the
sword agents. He steals the pair of shades.
This is meant to be a reference to his comic
book outfit. So he wears the green uniform
and he has the eyepieces this was going on
here were most of the episodes they were in,
especially the hollowing episode. They wore
versions of their comic book costumes that
is Agatha prepares to attack them again scarlet
which performs the same trick on heard that
she did on Ironman during Avengers: Age of
Ultron they even use that same visual effect
of her sneaking up on someone seemingly has
super speed to give her the hex vision. She
takes her back to when her coven was getting
ready to execute her. But then they played
for a couple big twist like twist upon twist
upon twist this time is sort of scarlet witch
putting her on trial raising the dead, so
to speak, raising up her coven to attacker
and remember, this is all happening inside
a vision. This was all a bit of a psychic
attack with them because Agatha is a very
learned which even though she's not quite
as powerful scarlet which is able to twist
the vision on her causing the undead coven
to turn on scarlet which is sort of harassed
her to trying get her to give her her abilities.
It was also really cool Easter egg for the
energy version of her headpiece when they
were still in the vision to that was meant
to be a bit of foreshadowing to her eventual
comic book costume reveal like oh no, this
is the full scarlet which will make it all
go away. I'll fix everything. You can just
live out your life here with this family you
created for yourself with vision in the children.
This also a lot of exposition in their fights
to especially their full-blown which fight
when they're floating in the air about how
magic works with the rules of magic are in
the MCU she's is that once someone cast the
spell it can't be changed. So no matter how
much power she got from scarlet which you
would never be able to fix the hex it was
always going to be broken just like you because
the hex itself is kind of a metaphor for what
was going on with scarlet which, but then,
as they blast their way out of the vision
back to reality. They start fighting in the
air that is like full-blown which fight so
as are flying around some you play sense that
there was good to be a big twist here because
is he seemingly fading away while she's blasting
her with chaos magic like here find take it
all take all my magic, but while this was
happening. She was very clearly blasting the
walls of the hex around her then the predictable
big twist of her dry firing when she tries
to open up on Wanda and Wanda throws her lesson
from episode eight back in her face like only
the which you cast the ruins can cast spells
and you see ruins around the walls of the
hex light up in like thousands of feet tall
just to let you know that scarlet which is
a smart person she can learn on the fly like
she keeps saying the episode. I have no idea
how my magic works. I'm not trying to do any
of this. I don't understand later in the episode.
They sort of pay that off like they let you
know know she can learn very fast, just like
Doctor strange learned magic very fast and
she will learn because she says I will understand
my powers of eventually they kind of gotten
that during the Doctor strange movie like
how did you get so powerful. So fast. He's
one of the most powerful sorcerers in the
universe when Avengers infinity war begins
and he hasn't been source or supreme for that
long is funny as it sounds, is mostly because
Doctor strange is just a really good at learning.
He's really good at school. Most of what he
does when he's not taking down other cosmic
villains is just reading a a lot of books.
They finally pay off the mind stone vision
when she reverses the spelling basically sucks
all of Agatha's magic out of her and takes
back the chaos magic that she took from Wanda
using it to upgrade herself to final boss
form scarlet witch and revealing her comic
book outfit with the way they light her up
like this is obvious he meant to be a call
back to them paying off the mind stone vision
is exactly what she looked like. Like if you
look at it this way you can see is the exact
same costume. So the mind stone way back to
the events of Captain America winter soldier
was basically showing her a vision of her
future when she goes final boss form scarlet
which you also notice that her accent comes
back fully like comes and goes during the
episode, but mostly towards the end the episode
after she's taken out Agatha Harkness. That's
when it really comes back. Generally running
away from her pastor her pain or herself anymore.
If it wasn't clear what was going on with
Agatha Harkness at the end of the episode.
She basically trapped her in this very self-contained
version of the hex personality as the nosy
neighbor even though she brought down the
entire hex so the rest of Westview just goes
back to the way it was before the hex except
Agatha Harkness is going to be the one person
walking around believing that she's this nosy
neighbor person the Wanda says nobody is gonna
bother you. Nothing bad is gonna happen to
you here trapping her in a prison of her own
mind, so to speak and saying that oh you know
even though your warning me about something
dangerous coming which like I said I believe
this Chthon the god of chaos. Wanda says if
I do need your help will know where to find
you. That's also to let you know the Agatha
Harkness will return in future MCU projects
not no idea when that would be. I'm not expecting
her to show up during Doctor strange 2 but
is always possible that they reference or
and also another big Doctor strange 2 Easter
egg if you look up at the Marquis in the movie
theater while this is happening you see that
it reads Oz the great and powerful. That's
actually a movie that Sam Raimi directed Sam
Raimi is the director of Doctor strange 2
and inevitably they head home. I feel like
everybody kind of sense where they were going
with the ending of this episode and she slowly
starts to receive the barrier of the hex so
it goes down basically in the order he came
up ending with their house so they have time
to put the twins to bed and say a proper goodbye
to them and she thanks them. Thank you for
choosing me to be your mother then she envision
go downstairs and say their final goodbyes.
She starts turning lights off around the living
room is sort of a metaphor for her turning
the hex officer to speak turning her spell
off vision has a really nice moment of turning
the light back on and talking about how he
really wanted to see her in that final moment.
I want to see you one last time, but also
you can think of. This is a clever reference
to some of the other dialogue they have referencing
him coming back again. Oh, we've said goodbye
many times, so therefore I think we will also
say hello again scarlet which also explains
how she created vision you are created from
the piece of the mind stone that lives within
me kind of explains the yellow mind stone
infinity stone energy that was flowing out
of her while he was being fabricated, but
she also says you are created from all my
emotions all my memories. So just another
way that they could bring him back in the
future is sort of the same thing with Billy
and Tommy that gets a little more complicated,
though, because she gave birth to them, but
remember she's fabricating them with this
background cosmic radiation using that is
energy to power her chaos magic spells obviously
there's a whole post credit scene with Billy
and Tommy all exclude that in the second to
so it just the beginning of many twists in
the future, but remember I talked about white
vision. He basically just flew off and we
never saw him again a lot of people were wondering
if you could re-create vision by combining
hex vision with white vision in the way they
explained Wanda's magic there's almost no
limits to what she can do so I will say yes,
you could probably do something like that
in the future, but bringing vision back is
just dependent upon them wanting to use him
in the future story and I don't know if he's
supposed to cameo during Doctor strange 2
I don't think so I'm assuming just Billy and
Tommy just because that post credit scene.
But then, as the rest of the hex comes down.
She winds up looking exactly the same as she
did when she first created the hex standing
the same place in the lot and she puts her
hood up and walks back to town with all the
townspeople just terrified of her is another
call back to Agatha Harkness saying they're
always going to treat you this way, people
will always be afraid of you for your power
but she is a really nice moment with Monica
Rambeau with a bond over both having lost
people she's like yes if I had your power.
I totally would've done the exact same thing
and brought my mother back to she changes
back in her comic book costume and flies off
outside of Westview to obviously wind up where
she is in the post credit scene all talk about
that in the second to but in the first made
credit scene you see Jimmy Woo organizing
the big FBI cleanup there a lot of funny Jimmy
Woo moments he is a little bit a close-up
magic little bit of sleight-of-hand to steal
the keys to his handcuffs and use the phone
to call the FBI to show up. Can you be here
in the hours we can make good on his threat.
I think he was such a hit during the series,
people loved him so much, they're definitely
going to bring Jimmy Woo back in future MCU
projects is going to like the new Phil Colson
just showing up in a bunch of different Marvel
movies that make a joke about Darcy just bailing
because debriefs are lame they give her that
really funny record drop moment because Tyler
Heyward was about to run over Billy and Tommy
with that giant Humvee it was hilarious how
badly he wanted to kill those kids they really
really wanted you to hate that character mission
accomplished. But then he gets carted away
by the FBI in handcuffs, presumably go to
prison who knows if we'll ever see him again.
He wasn't that great of a character. So I
would not be upset if we never saw him again
in administration shows up to bring Monica
Rambeau back to the movie theater and you
also notice that there's a huge Blade Runner
Easter egg on the Marquis so the 10 hazard
date is a reference to a really bad he was
talking about the replicant during Blade Runner
when he references all the wondrous things
that he saw in his travels around outer space.
I've seen things you people wouldn't believe
attack ships on fire off the shoulder of Orion.
I watched see beads glitter in the dark near
the 10 house or gate all those moments will
be lost in time, like tears in rain. So in
the context of the episode. The way they're
using that Easter egg is just a reference
to Monica Rambeau having adventures in outer
space in Captain Marvel to because that's
where she can show up in the movies next the
agent reveals yourself of the scroll, so that
she's basically working for Nick fury. He's
the old friend of her mother's and then says
that he wants to meet her and points up, which
is a reference to the space station from the
Spider-Man far from home post credit scene
with all the scrolls walking around so the
thing that Nick fury wants to speak to her
about it just plot that the will cover during
the Captain Marvel two movie. I feel like
they did a pretty decent job of giving her
a version of an origin story and sort of setting
the basis for what some of her comic book
abilities are even though Monica Rambeau has
had a bunch of different comic book names
and they reference a bunch of her different
powers from different eras in the comics.
I feel like that name that she's gonna go
with will be photon because that was her mother's
call sign, so she would probably go for that
first, but then in the final post credit scene
you see this giant mountain range where Wanda
is. I believe this is meant to be a reference
to the mountains of wonder core just her comic
book origin, because the cabin that she's
in his very Romani looking, but you see a
version of Wanda in her sweats just drinking
tea. Then going to boil some more pouring
a cup and as the camera pans into the other
room you see the real Wanda in her comic book
costume floating in the air studying the Darkhold
when all of a sudden she hears the voices
of Billy and Tommy crying out to her for help
from the multi-verse when they're saying mom
mom help please please is basically her hearing
voices from another dimension and because
she used chaos magic to create them is probably
the place where Chthon the god of chaos is
trapped right now, so obviously that's all
plot that the probably covered during Doctor
strange 2 I actually expected to see Benedict
Cumberbatch himself show up in some sort of
cameo scene I was a little disappointed that
we didn't see any kind of real cameos during
the episode, but they did reference a lot
of the stuff is coming up in the movies. The
whole thing with the connection to Spider-Man
3, the spider verse stuff that just more multi-verse
multiple dimensions alternate versions of
characters. The whole idea that Wanda is messing
with chaos Chthon and that's going to lead
to chaos multi-verse of madness. Madness chaos
you kind of get the references are making
so it really does seem like a phone is the
person that they're setting up in the MCU
right now, but like I said, because they like
to simplify comic book things in the MCU movies.
They might wind up changing his name or going
with a slightly different version that character,
but that is the reference that they're making,
but the whole thing with that alternate version
of Wanda. If you're wondering why it was their
version of Wanda sitting there drinking tea
that was Wanda showing that she'd mastered
astral projection like you saw during the
first Doctor strange movie just to throw anyone
off who might be monitoring her, like the
other Avengers or Nick fury up in his space
station or even Doctor strange himself so
that she could read the book and learn from
the Darkhold without people knowing what she
was doing, but as for Billy and Tommy that
sort of explains why Wanda is so invested
in what's happening during Doctor strange
2. Obviously Doctor strange would take an
interest in her having the Darkhold like okay
Wanda you might be very powerful. Urine avenger
your good person you want to do good, but
I can't let you walk around without book also
the fact that she doesn't understand everything
yet is a good way to explain how she accidentally
causes really big problems is a really easy
way to explain how Doctor strange gets involved,
so she needs Doctor strange's help to understand
what's going on here in Doctor strange needs
her help because of her power they're still
in the middle of filming. Doctor strange 2
right now. I don't think we can see a trailer
for that till may be the end of the year I'm
in a cross my fingers and say hopefully they'll
drop some footage by the end of the year by
the time Spider-Man 3 releases because Doctor
strange 2 is coming out in March next year
it'll literally be the next MCU movie right
after Spider-Man 3, but if there any big Easter
eggs that you saw in the episode that I didn't
mention the video just write them below in
the comments. Obviously there's just so much
stuff. The trying to set up, but I feel like
it was a pretty solid series. I wasn't sure
what to expect, but this does give you something
to benchmark all the other Marvel Disney plus
series. My next couple of videos will be for
some of these bigger concepts like the Darkhold
Chthon chaos magic in the MCU in what they're
doing with this. So leave all your requests
in the comments below. So what can happen
next week is next Friday. There's going to
be of behind the scenes episode for Wandavision
and a special Marvel legends episode for falcon
winter soldier. I will do videos for both
of those things, especially if they drop anything
really cool and then the week after that is
falcon winter soldier episode one all my videos
for that will be just like my Wandavision
episodes and then after falcon winter soldier
will get all the low-key episodes, but while
you wait for everything. Click here for brand-new
first look at Thor 4 love and thunder in some
clips and click here for all my Wandavision
episodes in Easter eggs and learn all about
Monica Rambeau. Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and I'll see you guys tonight!